so rick wilson is the co-founder of the
lincoln project the project which was
founded uh
2019 by
former republicans and incumbent
republicans to basically
prevent donald trump from being
re-elected rick thanks so much for
making time again for deutsche belly i'm
delighted to be back to be back with you
enos
so it's uh about one year when we saw
the storming of the capital uh from
trump supporters basically to prevent
the peaceful transition of power yes
how do you feel when you see these
images again
well i i you know unfortunately
my colleagues and i predicted
that there would be violence and that
trump would not cede power willingly or
peacefully uh we had we wrote an article
in the washington post in december about
this time
um
last year
and
and it was prescient in terms of
of the of our understanding that you
know the the kind of person donald trump
is the kind of politics he represents
you know one of the most fundamental
norms of american politics is the
peaceful transition of power you have to
have in a in a democratic republic you
have to have somebody who loses an
election be willing to lose they have to
be willing to lose and if they lose fair
and square no matter how brutal the
campaign is traditionally whether it was
you know in our lifetimes very contested
elections al gore for instance at the
end of the day he fought he fought hard
but he didn't do violence he didn't
encourage violence
um
and and you know he he said okay i lost
i conceived we knew donald trump would
never do that we understood from the
beginning his psychology would prevent
him from doing that
and and the people around him who
frankly are are authoritarians or at
least authoritarian adjacent
uh were increasingly unwilling to play
by the rules of american political life
and discourse and so we we knew it was
coming that didn't make it any less
outrageous
uh the scope and the the the degree to
which those folks were encouraged by
donald trump and his his his advisors
and his allies um was something that
you know
when it when it happened the monster got
out of the box very quickly they lost
control over it um and and we came
within uh a few minutes in this country
of having a an angry violent mob
of trump supporters you know if they had
run into members of congress or the u.s
senate there would have been bloodshed
and it would have shattered this country
even more than than a than an attack on
our our democratic system would have
would you say that gender 6 was a real
turning point of american politics
i believe it was
i believe it was a very consequential
day
because it told
two problematic stories
the first was that there was a
justification
based on the big lie that trump won the
election he did not win the election
under any circumstances by no
by no measure or merit did he win this
election
but it it locked in the minds of
millions of people that whatever actions
they took were justified because it was
stolen
they believe they live in a country with
an illegitimate president with a with a
with a fraudulently elected president we
all know that's wrong but it doesn't
doesn't stop it from becoming a part of
their mythology
and the second reason i think it's such
a consequential day
is
political violence in america has always
been at the very ragged edges
and whether it's political violence on
the left or the right it's always been
on the very ragged edges
this mainstreamed it where millions of
americans didn't see the people uh
charging the capital one six
as as traitors they didn't see them as
insurrectionists they saw them
as people like them they saw them as
people taking a stand again for that for
that other part of the big lie they saw
them as people who were justified in
their actions
and you know the fragility of democracy
around the world
has become increasingly apparent in the
last three or four years the rise of
authoritarianism and nationalism and
personality cult politics has become
increasingly evident
and i'm sorry my dogs are gonna embark
on it today
um
increasingly evident and and that
problem is of such a scale
and of such a degree
um that you know the
it was symptomatic of something that's
happening in other countries around the
world but in america we had a certain
degree of pride in our peaceful
transitions of power
and in our political systems resilience
and resistance to that kind of activity
and
unfortunately we were wrong about that
and and it's something that you know at
the lincoln project we had to really you
know we looked at our goals for 2020 and
the goals were to
prevent donald trump from seeking off or
gaining office for a second term
to you know neutralize a lot of the
enablers of trump
and finally to to push back and to break
the back of trumpism and i mean we used
trumpism as a shorthand for
authoritarian nationalism the the
difficulty was we did great on the first
assignment did okay on the second but on
the third we never really devoted the
time that we should have
to to breaking that movement as
effectively as we could and to
shattering that idea that that that you
know that kind of violence-based
nationalist movement um was justified or
acceptable in american policies we
should have done more on that and that's
one of the things we've had to refocus
on as the year has showed us that
you know trump himself is continuing to
repeat the big lie
fox news has continued to repeat the big
lie
um and that's the most important
normative force in american politics
um and so you know we've had to we've
had to recalibrate a lot of what we've
done and needed to do
um but that fight is obviously going to
have to continue
yeah and that would be my question i
mean the
pentagon just put out a warning that one
of the biggest threats uh here in the
states is really like
domestic terrorism so some people really
are worried that we might face another
kind of civil war what's what's your
thinking about that how violent yet
it could get 1860 violent that's
unfortunately the truth
and you know it it is it is a country
right now that has factionalized
and balkanized among uh or or in
geographic terms in political terms and
in social terms in a way that's never
been seen in america
since the
1860s
and that danger
that that we face right now comes from
the fact that this country is so
fundamentally at odds where there's no
presumption of goodwill
on either side where there's no ability
to compromise or willingness to
compromise on either side of the
equation
and where the republican party has
transformed itself in this post-trump
era
they've said what we call as we said
they said the quiet part out loud
and the quiet part is we will contain
um
you know we will retain power at any
cost
we will we will hold the the offices we
wish to hold no matter what the other
side wants we will decide who counts the
votes how the votes are counted where
the votes are counted how the votes are
certified they have built a structure in
a very short window
of an autocratic structure in a very
short window of time that has put
american democracy in an enormous degree
of peril
um and so the the
the threat of violence
is
unfortunately and this isn't just in
america but the threat of violence is an
enormously powerful political tool
it is something that that that people
trying to live their normal lives and
trying to live their their their
everyday existences
do not want to face
it intimidates because it is meant to it
frightens because it is meant to
and there's only one side of the
political equation in america right now
that is embrace violence
there's only one side that's excusing it
as a political tactic and that's the
republican party you know of which i was
a member for 30 plus years
so when i travel the states and i do
that quite a bit my feeling is that more
and more uh people really are turning
their back to politics they're just
tired they're sick of it they don't want
to know anything about it anymore well
you know also
in that
in that old in that old sort of
semi-cliched phrase you know
americans may not be interested in
politics but politics is interested in
them
and so we're in a country now where you
can't avoid the politicization of every
aspect of life
i mean we're facing up to a
a a a coveted crisis that has cost us
nearly a million dead americans
and there are people who look at whether
they'll get treated
or vaccinated or given or get a booster
shot
they look at that as a political act
they look at you know whether they wear
a mask in public or don't as a political
act
they look at what kind of car they drive
where they live where they send their
kids to school as a fundamentally
political
statement
and i think it makes the country
more divided and weaker
uh along those fault lines that could
lead us to civil conflict in this
country and and it
the idea that we can escape it is is
yeah it's a natural response
but in the in the minds of people who
are just fatigued they spent five years
watching trump burn down every
institution in this country
tear apart you know americans at every
different you know
fracture point
and they are tired they're exhausted you
know we're now we've lived through two
years of covet
we've come out of the trump economic
crisis that happened because he
mismanaged coven so badly on the front
uh front end of the problem
but we still face enormous stresses and
difficulties there's a rising in worry
about inflation in the country and so
americans are they are driven to sort of
turn inward but on the other hand all
the other forces in society have pushed
them outwards so that so that everything
is interpreted politically now and
everything is seen through a political
uh you know
as a political signifier every act is
not seen as a political signifier
we are facing a midterm election a
little bit less than a year from now um
talk a little bit about that and then
unfortunately i think we have to talk
about what all that means for the
possibility that donald trump will be
running again sure
well look the midterms mid-term
elections are always extraordinarily
difficult for the incumbent political
party
and there's only been one example in our
lifetimes i was talking to my partner
stewart stevens this morning about this
you know we were very much involved in
the 2002
uh midterms which was the only time in
modern american history where the
incumbent party retained seats now that
was primarily because the the 9 11
attacks turned the 2002 election into a
referendum on national security
but when you look back at
incumbent parties holding the the the
house
um
it is a very difficult equation in 1994
you know you saw bill clinton won and
the democrats in night in 92 the
democrats got wiped out in 1994. in 2004
uh the republicans had you know a very
two on two and four had very two very
good cycles in 2006 blown out because
that was when it went back to normal in
19
pardon me in 2010 barack obama had had a
sweeping victory and a sweeping victory
in the house in in 2010 he got blown out
62 seats
and so that cycle is something very
common and very you know explicable in
american politics
and so that puts the democrats at the
first disadvantage the second
disadvantage is redistricting in red
states is engineered essentially that is
going to get the republicans 12 to 14
seats without breaking the sweat they
don't have to do anything they'll just
design seats that republicans only can
only only republicans can win
then there are the headwinds of a
divided democratic party where the
progressives want everything tomorrow
they want the birthday cake and the pony
um and the moderates want to win
elections and take back you know a
larger majority in the senate and the
larger majority in the house
and and all of them are mad at biden
because he doesn't do either what the
progressives want or the centrists want
um
biden has had a very you know he's had a
he's he's actually had a couple of very
enormously important accomplishments
that that got under sold and got
forgotten about and and i mean this in
with the sense of tough love to my
democratic colleagues
they're terrible at politics they are
the worst thing they are so bad at
elections
there's no there's a reason why
republicans beat them consistently
because republicans grow up in a
campaign culture that prizes victory
over everything else that may be a moral
that may be difficult that may be
problematic but it's true
and the democrats have this idea that
policy will win elections etc and and i
don't know that they're that they
they're that they're mentally prepared
to run the kind of races they have to
run in
2022
um to hold the house and to hold the
senate and the margins are so narrow in
both bodies
that it is going to be an extremely
difficult thing if they don't understand
they're fighting against people
you know the democrats are playing chess
and the republicans are eating the
pieces they don't they're not going to
play by the rules they're going to go
out and try to make this into a huge
culture war they're going to try to make
this into a huge um
social war
and the democrats really need to focus
on you know
a broad electoral strategy that is not
going to be you know about
fantasies of like critical race theory
and all these other things the
republicans are trying to bait them into
fighting off then to fight on the
economy
which is the number one issue in the
country by far by an order of magnitude
in some cases
and
and
they need to focus on the on on that
narrow slice of republican disaffected
republican voters who are not trumpers
the kind of people that you know built
the lincoln project and the lincoln
project talks to all the time
those are voters who may be republican
behaviorally but they cannot
in good conscience vote for the people
that are going to bring donald trump
back now what happens if the democrats
lose the house there's a very meaningful
chance that you will have donald trump
named as the speaker of the house you do
not in american politics have to be an
elected official to be named the speaker
of the house
there are about 80 votes in the house
right now in the republican caucus that
would vote for trump uh you know over
any other human being
um there's a meaningful chance that
happens
at that point you know chaos reigns in
the country
um
if it's not trump it's going to be
someone like jim jordan or marjorie
taylor greene or matt gates or paul
gosar who becomes the speaker
and that person will immediately
initiate impeachment hearings against
joe biden a whole suite of
investigations no matter how spurious
and ridiculous they are against the
biden administration
all to set up the predicates for the
2022 election our 2024 election excuse
me um in which trump will return
it is our belief
that he will return what however if
donald trump is not dead or in jail he
is running for president
there is no question we see all the
signs in his fundraising in all the the
the
political action groups he's putting
together in his continued press into
media
um his continued role
with republican voters look there's a
lot of polling out there on this and it
averages around 70 percent of republican
voters want donald trump to run again
and will vote for him over any other
republican candidate in that field
so no one's going to run against him in
the republican primary i mean for all
the for all that ted cruz and rob and
ron desantis and greg abbott and josh
hawley and and and all these other marco
rubio all these other guys want to be
president
if trump runs in the primary
they will drop out
so fast your head will spin and trump
will be the republican nominee in fact
he won't even end up having to to run
for the nomination most of the states
republican parties will just declare
that he's the nominee that's it it's
done so he will have we we will start
the campaign
in
probably january of 2023
it will there will not be an interval
there will not be a break or a gap it
will be a constant campaign the
democrats will not understand how to
fight it
because they will be facing republican
dominance in the house constant hearings
and investigations and they won't know
how to push back on it
trump will go out there continue to
drive the states into positions where
they pass these voting registration and
voting uh an election restrictions
which minimizes the ability of
african-american voters and hispanic
voters to get out and vote
there's a great example in georgia of a
a trump group took over a local
elections board
this week
and they have now closed six of the
seven polling places in the
african-american community in the county
it's not a coincidence it's a plan it's
a program there are smart people running
all this they are maybe evil but they're
very bright people we know them we all
worked with them for years and years
so it is going to be a very difficult if
beating the dem if the democrats hold on
in 2022 trump will still run in 24. it
will make it more difficult it will be
more problematic it will not be a
straight shot for him but it is going to
be you know i tell my my ex-republican
friends and my democratic friends don't
have a failure of imagination we have we
all failed in our imagination in 2015
and 2016 because everyone thought how is
a clown like donald trump a game show
host like donald trump win the
nomination that's absurd it will never
happen
and he did
and then they said you know um you know
he'll never beat hillary clinton she's
runs runs a great campaign she's so
smart she's so established he's so smart
but he did
so we have to be in a position where we
understand the realities where we don't
fail to imagine the worst case scenario
and
the worst case scenario is if trump is
elected in 2024
by january of 2025 we don't have a
functioning democracy in this country
he will immediately take as much action
as he can to essentially become
president for life and people think i'm
being dramatic or exaggerating that but
i know the people he is surrounded by
uh guys like steve bannon and stephen
miller they are
unashamed
authoritarians they are unashamed
fascists they are unashamed statists
they believe that this country needs to
be fundamentally broken and remade in
their image and they will use him as the
vector for that for that attempt
is there anyone rick in the republican
party
who is really going to fight that within
the gop i mean those who live
look liz cheney and adam kinzinger are
doing yeoman's work
right now
there are about 30 republicans in the
house who are
publicly for trump and privately opposed
but they will not do anything they fear
for their lives political violence has
has terrified all of them they get death
threats all the time
they they do not want to be killed by
them all
and that's one of the reasons that one
six was one of the one of the it was
a darkly brilliant political move by
steve bannon
and and roger stone and and alex jones
all these people that organized it
because it sent a message not just to
democrats but to republicans if you
cross us if you do not support trump and
the big lie we will come and try to kill
you
and that's not a functioning republic at
that point that is that is a country
where where we have slipped into
a degree of danger uh about whether
we're going to continue in this
experiment um you know as a as a as a
democracy and as a as a as a republic
um
then you know maybe on the on the
precipice of failure and i think if
trump wins in 24
it would it will fail we will have we
will have lost what america uh had been
for 245 years
so rick until then um what does the
world
have to expect from the states i mean
they they will be so self-conscious or
self-centered in anything they're doing
well look uh i do know that the biden
administration understands that we can't
withdraw from the world and we have to
re-establish
um some of the normative forces that
that you know led the the nato alliance
for instance for years to serve as a
force of stabilization trump tried to
undermine it and destroy it
um
you know the blind administration is
trying to rebuild that they're trying to
rebuild a sense of cohesiveness in the
world order
it is a hard hill to climb when you have
a very narrow political
uh margin in both the house and the
senate it is a hard hill to climb when
people like ted cruz are blocking the
appointment of ambassadors blocking the
appointment of military officials
blocking the appointment of
of people who would be in charge of
american foreign policy um
so it makes it much more difficult
to to to try to shore up
those institutions especially at a time
when a
when china is expanding its global reach
and global power
when russia you know although russia may
be a third-rate economy it's got a
first-rate intelligence service and it's
disrupting you know europe everywhere
from belarus to ukraine to the to the
baltics i mean in all these cases
strong international leadership from
either the us or u.s and its allies
together is a necessary
element of of future stability but it's
going to be difficult to accomplish that
in many ways
while we have so much political uh
uncertainty and instability here at home
in the sense
so
give me a little bit hope at the end of
it
what could happen
you know there's a there's no joke
that god protects drunks and americans
um and and and look
it not it isn't just the sort of
providential nature
of of of the american story because the
nature has been america has had a lot of
providential good luck over time it's
not just that because you know luck is
not a strategy but there are millions
and millions of americans
who are who are increasingly
understanding the risks we face and the
trouble ahead
uh and those those millions of americans
have come out they've crossed party
lines in many cases
um and and i think at some point
even the democrats who are not the most
graceful or skillful political party
uh they will come to understand they're
in the fight of their lives and i mean
that not in the political sense but in
the literal sense that you know you've
got to win these you've got to win
against these people and this movement
or the consequences are are almost
unimaginable
okay well i thank you and uh i'm sure we
will continue this conversation i would
love to thank you